let's go next to Daisy from is it from
reading or from reading reading and it's
spelled reading but I know that it's
pronounced different ways depending on
where in the world we are talking about
yeah um it's it's uh reading actually
are you doing David can you hear me I'm
doing well we have significantly
degraded audio quality where it's the
sort of like robot voice thing that's
happening but let's see if you can get
your question in if nothing else
oh boy okay David can you hear me better
I hope my question is
in the Republican party they seem to
focus around trends
uh people a lot
and I think it's because in my view that
uh that with trans people
they are making changes to their bodies
with
um like
you know with whatever their doctors
recommend right and they and the
Republican party is attacking this in a
way that they uh have an attack
LGBT community in the in the past like
with the the gang Community for example
and I'm just wondering your thoughts
about whether they will ever let up on
the trans Community like give us a break
kind of yeah I think so I mean as I've
said before
a while it was like when will they stop
obsessing about gay men and gay sex and
the answer unfortunately for the trans
Community was when they've moved on to
being obsessed with the Trans Community
I do believe eventually Republicans will
move on the problem is they'll scapegoat
some other group so someone else has it
coming to them if you know what I mean
yeah I understand that I just I'm hoping
for something to change
um I see a lot of change happening in I
think it's Montana
um with the
info
um silenced by the I think they'll let
the Republican legislature there Daisy
you cut out when you said who was
silenced but let me look into what's
happening in Montana I'm Gonna Let You
Go just because the connection is really
an uphill battle for us but I do
appreciate your question and uh hearing
from you about what is a very important
issue I do believe they will move on
from trans people but someone else is
going to then be in their crosshairs
which is a scary thing